hi welcome to the coding portion of
lesson for now we're going to create
some conferences a conference management
application really needs to be able to
create and save conferences after we've
created some conferences we're going to
learn how to run queries and use filters
to query those conferences for example
suppose you've got a trip planned to san
francisco in june and you want to find
out if there's any conference is going
on then i'll show you how to write the
code to find out then we're going to
delve deeper into indexes we're going to
look at the index configuration file and
then we're going to use the index viewer
in the admin console to explore our
indexes to make sure that they're
serving so that our users don't get
index non-existent errors another thing
or application really needs to be able
to do is to allow users to register for
conference and the registration process
needs to take place inside a transaction
suppose you give us your credit card
number you want to make sure you've
really got a seat before the payment
goes through so we're going to use the
registration process to practice writing
transactions let's go create some
conferences